je suis ravi de pouvoir transmettre ce
titre à la prochaine candidate qui vivra
une très belle aventure comme moi même
j'ai vécu elle n'est pas encore finie me
reste encore quelques mois profiter de
mon titre
comment s'est déroulée cette année cette
année s'est très bien déroulé nous avons
pu donc aller dans divers manifestations
et même si c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
l'annulation de l'élection
l'escroc en france nous avons pu quand
même avoir des manifestations en
martinique et pouvoir en fait montré là
que les rondes ne sont pas cachés donc
nous allons pu être présent sur divers
manifestations
aujourd'hui je préfère la prochaine
élection d'un catalyseur alors on est
très bien préparé on prépare les
candidates on est
on est attentif on les aide à pouvoir
prétendre au titre et faire un
magnifique show une magnifique élections
le 30 sept
le comité miss ronde c'est pas juste un
concours de beauté ça aide également les
candidates à pouvoir à pouvoir se mieux
se sentir dans leur peau à pouvoir être
ce qu'elle ce qu'elles sont malgré leur
leur poids donc ça aide
et ça change aussi les mentalités sur
les idées reçues qu'on peut avoir sur
les routes